what's up y'all it's called proper 1501
and i'm here chilling with the bootleg
kid podcast
boulay cat podcast we got 1501 in here
mr carl crawford is here man
first of all congratulations on uh the
success of just everything
you know but right now you got erica
going crazy
um for people who don't know who you are
man kind of give us a run down on
who you are what you do and uh and you
know just kind of see
some of your background man oh i'll be
up you know
call my name is carl crawford i'm from
houston texas
uh i actually started out playing
baseball i got a 14-year career where i
ended up playing my last three years
here with the dodgers um decided to
retire from baseball and got into the
music i did not realize you're the same
carl crawford that played baseball
you didn't know that you know
[Laughter]
oh [ __ ] yeah that's [ __ ] i guess i
just
watched it all the time i get the
reaction because you know not a lot of
people
go from the sports thing to the rap [ __ ]
and it worked successfully none of them
really
like zach randolph no a lot of people
know randolph's kind of low key behind
money back yo
yeah man him we talked about it me and
him always like
like you know me you the only ones kind
of pulled off yeah because mello tried
to do it in a fair a lot of amari
stadamine had a label and it didn't work
out wow
you know what i'm saying so it's like
[ __ ] i just
you know what i'm saying i felt like i
can do it because of my connections in
houston
and i decided to take it serious here we
are
you do you got the right recipe whatever
you're doing something about female
talent you know how to find that yeah i
mean
you know it's just talent period yeah
yeah yeah
so it was like one of those dreams to
have like you say for some reason
uh sports and hip-hop go together yeah
they always want to do what you do
you notice they always come to the state
and want to do what we doing we want to
do what they do so
i mean look at lebron he just said he
want to put a put a whole album
yeah like some dj khaled type [ __ ] yeah
like for what bro you're really you're
like you got it you just got to do it
one of those things so what year did you
end your baseball career i ended in
2016.
so that was not that long ago um had you
already started the label prior to and
like like leaving baseball
no i hadn't i hadn't uh started it yet
but the idea had already been in my head
for
a few years quite some time um
and when when i retired i just
immediately went right into it like i
didn't
blink was megan your first artist no
megan wasn't my first artist
she was she was like like my sixth or
seventh artist
she's the first one that really really
likes
that's crazy and uh you know it's
it's a lot of people who might have had
six or seven artists prior
would have been like all right you know
what i tried it it didn't work out i got
three and just i'm
it's a wrap you know yeah i mean it's
just that when we had
her she was steady going so you know as
long as you got somebody you got one
person
you know it's kind of growing up you can
kind of keep managing
others and hoping that they uh do the
same thing at some point
do you feel that you know obviously
having a successful baseball career you
have
the finances that a lot of other people
might not have to break an artist
office show cause that's one thing i
learned you know what i'm saying it
costs a lot of money to be in this game
you know
it's a lot of it's not cheap to break an
article then you got to deal with the
finesses like you know
as an athlete nobody's going to take us
seriously so you're going to deal with a
lot of people that can tell you this and
that and they
you know they're going to take the bread
and do whatever they want with it so
it's like you have to be careful for all
that stuff
yeah it's like a lot of people don't
understand you know obviously
there's the real slow grind but then
there's you know overnight [ __ ] where
something goes viral but then like
really to build a art like i seen what
y'all did with megan it was like
really like that [ __ ] ain't cheap man
like did you did you like follow a model
like
who did you or you just created your own
recipe when he's coming
kind of just went along with it you know
any big homies in the music game that
were kind of
you know baby game
i'm always asking him for advice you
know that's the only person really you
know that i get advice from but
i just saw a culture like i i sit back
and watch like drake come to iowa city
houston and just
have drake weekend i mean when he first
started coming out when he was with jay
prince junior yeah
[Music]
right just like a nobody so i actually
saw this process from
start to finish on how they groomed the
prison and he just did like one little
houston song and it just houston landed
texas
crazy yeah i was like man [ __ ] all they
did was
found somebody with talent and kept them
in the cool spots around houston and
next day you know
he paid a lot of homage to houston too
and he loved houston cause we the one
broke them so when i saw that i was like
man i could i could do that
you know it's it's crazy because um when
we think of hip-hop
we think of football we think of
basketball we barely ever really think
of baseball right baseball is like
a is it's a sport that i feel like
is hard to get youth into because it's
because you know
to watch a baseball game it's about
strategy it's about
so much more than see me i can't watch
it
for too long i go to a live game but on
tv i can't i can't watch this you hear a
lot of people say you got to know
somebody you know and then you can go
live but
you know what i'm saying like you got to
be into it but you know
that's one of the things you just got to
like it but at the game yeah the game
you get faced with hot
[Music]
what position did you play outfield okay
so you're in left field
so you heard some [ __ ] in the outfield
oh man what's the what because
we always hear about like fans talking
[ __ ] i've heard of city
well i heard a lot of people saying
boston got racist fans they said utah as
well
you talk you're no utah baseball team
james
jesus christ nobody [ __ ] playing babe
they got the jazz bro relax
hey i was just trying to i don't like
utah that's what i thought
like like you ever hear any racist [ __ ]
or any crazy [ __ ] out there whatever
they say man you know
you're an athlete and they're gonna say
what they're gonna say now one of the
funniest things somebody ever told me
was like you know um
he was like hey crawford man you
couldn't throw a [ __ ] baby shower
you know what i'm saying did you giggle
at that when he heard that did you
giggle it's a good one like
you know what i'm yeah like but
sometimes they just yeah you know
they're trying to
hey they don't want to see their team
lose so how you feel about the other
athletes that got a problem with the
crowd yelling at them like
like they they get all hot jump in the
crowd
y'all got to go do something else for a
living you know cause it's just kind of
what comes with it comes with it yeah
they gon they gonna act the food
especially them east coast teams
boston i just say like new york
play playing in boston is is
they got a certain affinity for the for
the red sox right
right they're real passionate very like
like
you can argue they got the most
passionate fans yeah they do
you can't argue
what was like like being in boston and
being a was this was this was after the
the uh
world series like when they the drought
ended uh
what dropped you know when there was
this red sox drought you know the babe
ruth curtis
when i was there was after so they
wasn't as bad before that draw i heard i
wasn't there but i heard it was
just really rough but they kind of
lightened up right
a little bit but it was still boston so
you know you just deal with
hey man it's all a family of father
you'll have a
five-year-old kid flipping you the bird
you know what i'm saying like
that's some gangsters that's gangster
that's that's why you say something back
you you the
you're the bad guy they're gonna try to
turn around see tanner go like this
[ __ ] you tanner yeah so you know it'd be
why
um i just had big u up here
and uh we were talking about his
original deal with nipsey
he had a production deal with nipsey
that nipsey signing like oh nine and it
was for
he's like 10 years right and me and big
you were talking and i was like damn 10
years
that's crazy right like when you think
about work that's that's
a lot of time right but you know he was
saying he was like yeah but what people
don't see is the five
years that led up to even being able to
make money
right you know what i'm saying and the
idea that
well if i got you here you know i got
you here so i could
you know it's almost like you know
investing in something you know what i'm
saying like
you should be able to reap the benefits
of that right and he brought you up in
the situation that you had with megan
and well me and dj had and megan's a
sweetheart we we interviewed her she's
so nice
um but we had a conversation and it's
like and i manage artists you know
and um it's it's like yo
i'm not saying that megan wouldn't have
made it with or without you right
because she's [ __ ] immensely talented
but but you took a chance on her you
invested in her
she signed the paperwork um
what would you say like like what did
you learn from that situation
see in that situation man it's it's so
many like loose things with that you
know what i'm saying like
with me and megan she new to the
business i'm new to the business
we had a mutual guy that's her manager
right now t ferris
you know what i'm saying shout out t
ferris well i don't know if we shot him
well i just i just remember paul wall
used to rap about him you know but this
guy
he really took advantage of me and her
not knowing what's going on right
so you know if i were to learn anything
i would just say that like
because people don't know that contract
i had nothing to do with it this guy t
ferris and her mom did the whole thing
so i'm new i'm just excited about being
in the business
you're the baseball guy you got you got
the you you got the bag i just retired
two years in the game
right top of the music scene right [ __ ]
so i'm not even i'm letting this guy run
all my business stuff because
you know i don't i'm clearly advanced
and i don't know what's going on
also a link to the music industry yeah
so i don't i don't know what's going on
so they do this deal and
you know they bring it to me cool they
happy with it fine you know
and um um when things hit the fan
you know when the big people come i
didn't unders i still couldn't even
understand the concept of what was
happening you know at the time because
it was moving so far i didn't know a
manager gonna come in one day and
sign like i didn't understand none of
this stuff so
of course when the majors want to come
in the managers they look for any little
thing and they found
these little problems with this contract
and
you know all of a sudden i'm the bad guy
but at the end of the day i just learned
that you know
um that type of stuff you need to just
know about it
contracts you know understand do people
the right
way you know and just try to because i
think to try to be on top of your
business
more well i think that the perception
was that you had signed her to a shitty
deal
yeah and and i'm not sure that that's
the the i mean i think that that might
be
obviously misleading that's what social
media read social media
with that you know like like i say with
the deal like
okay we gave a 60 40 profit split like
we
like nobody gets no which is great you
know people just didn't understand
contracts and they wanted to just blame
somebody
you know they wanted to get out of the
contract they wanted to just avoid it
she just wanted to go to roc nation and
be
under jay-z and all that cap [ __ ] but
you know
the thing was all they they never they
never called me they never
said nothing to me they waited for me to
say one little thing on the internet
oh you made me mad right there you know
so it was like they found that one thing
to just turn everything against me and i
i'm clueless so just imagine
you and a person y'all partners me megan
we ain't nothing wrong with us
it's it's unt ferris that he was doing
this
in your opinion he was doing that yeah
he handling his business moving
you know and the next day she's saying
hey [ __ ] y'all you know what i'm saying
and i'm
just imagine you don't even know what's
happening you know what i'm saying you
just like wha
what's going on i've never met megan
never had a problem with each other
always gave her what she wanted never
told her no a day in my life you know
what i'm saying
and it was just like damn you know i'm
so what happened
well of course when you call the t
ferris guy he's
playing both sides doing the end around
he called me crying one day saying that
oh she don't want to [ __ ] with us no
more and i
you know that's going to get me going
like oh she don't want to [ __ ] with us
as well
but [ __ ] we just gonna handle our
business yo but then you go tell her
he said [ __ ] you too you know what i'm
saying that type of [ __ ] wow
the next thing you know she like to this
day man had never even talked about
nothing that happened this guy if you
notice this guy t ferris you never hear
from
he never say nothing you never nothing
because he don't want to
want to say nothing he claims that oh i
just don't want the fame and this and
that but
use the cause for all this problem like
it never was a problem with me and megan
but this guy he he hides and he like
you know he he probably gonna try to you
know
say oh oh i'm defamation for character
the stuff he'd like to say i don't care
because i know what the truth was but
you know if it wasn't for this guy when
her mother passed he jumped in up there
if it weren't for this guy
me and megan to still be cool right now
and as of right now yeah do you still
are you still benefiting from her career
at all yeah i mean we still like this
you still got the pa
okay okay so people want to say oh you
running a little jade
you know and this and that was like well
that's the only person i knew
who understood what was going on like
who else was i gonna call
you know what i'm saying had not i did
that rock nation was going to take
everything from me i wouldn't have got
nothing you know i'm saying i would have
just been like
well they would they look at you like
you're the little guy you know you don't
got nothing we're going to take your
[ __ ] from you
like you don't got it so having having
jay step in and speak up for you
how important was that it was everything
i wouldn't like i said i wouldn't have
nothing
it wasn't they wasn't coming they didn't
come in and like
to like say um oh we want to give you
your shell
it was like nah we wanted oh you know so
um when i saw that you know i had to go
i had to go do what i had to go do you
know what i'm saying i'm from field war
that's a notorious
place in houston texas this is where of
course prince is from right yeah we all
from the same neighborhood
he you know in the business he reasoned
one of the reasons why i even got
to doing this of course rap a lot man
yeah so i was like [ __ ] that's the only
person i know i can call to kind of just
even see
what's going on it wasn't like a scare
tactic to try to scare megan
or do nothing like that you know this
was really the only person i could call
so do you think looking back at every
how it all went down do you think
you could handle anything different or
you think you do everything exactly the
same
erica i try to like be more you know
like see for me
you know i wasn't is uh
in tune what i mean like just like
speaking you know like like like how you
were treated like a little sister [ __ ]
communication right right right
but i just did that by design i'm like
hey [ __ ] i don't want to bother all the
time so
i could have had a problem could have
had a better relationship with her where
we spoke more
and that way uh the stuff in between
wouldn't have been so cloudy and they
they couldn't like like infiltrate the
situation like they did
and that was the most hurtful part
because man this guy played little
league baseball together
so you've been knowing tv so and so he
he like he hustled me the whole time he
made me think
that we was partners and we was friends
and all this stuff and the whole time he
was
he was running against me and when he
got the chance to make a move on me
he bam do you think that being an
athlete coming into hip-hop
that because i've seen it happen we're
like
promoters or managers they look at they
look at an athlete because they know you
got the bag
and they're like it's it's almost like
they're hustling you the whole time
it's a hustle and i have to learn and
that's why like i i've known guys
let me tell you this i know who you are
as a baseball player but i had no idea
that it was the same carl crawford
so i thought you played for utah
apparently so no no
no but what i'm saying is that it says a
lot about the the what you've built with
1501
is that it's independent of and that was
about and that was by design like if you
notice on my instagram i
never post baseball so i wanted to
create my whole new identity whatever it
was i was going to be doing
so you flipped right away but i had
buddies like
trying to do music playing and they'll
be like tell me how much money they
waste and i'll be like damn you know
like
you know i said but in my mind i was
calculating on what i was gonna need to
do
because i knew i was gonna take a real
run at it at some point and it's worked
out
it has worked out and that and and um
you got this
you know obviously for people who don't
know who erica banks is the busted
challenge is probably the biggest tick
tock moment of the last year so
yeah that was just like a gift from oh
and it was an older wreck it wasn't old
but it was
been out for like six seven months right
yeah we had put it out and watched or
something like that right oh so yeah
nine months like much you know
worked it did well you know we was
getting ready to go to another song but
it's like god just paid us for for the
hard work from march to december so was
the challenge designed
or somebody some some random tick tocker
just did it
it just randomly happened damn that's
why
you just said it just pop off that tick
tock and just do that
look i didn't have a tic tac nothing i
saw
when i saw those first challenges come
in i was like
so when did you know when the challenge
was popping up when did you know okay we
got something here
i knew when the first day erica posted
like six of them in a row
but she wasn't posting the right ones to
me right like posting like
the ones she thought was cool i was like
[ __ ]
i'll even post another one so i want to
go look for the ones that she had when i
went to go
look it was like you couldn't even find
it it was just it was over
my god you look up that damn hashtag and
it's like gosh
i can't even it's out of my hands now
tick-tock everything oh man that's crazy
hey i know you're watching the interview
right now thank you for watching we
gotta interrupt this for a special
uh announcement from our good good good
sponsors over at odd socks
i have all socks on my feet as we speak
these are nwo socks you know i mean the
wolf pack you know somehow
shout out to um odd socks though if
you're watching this
go to oddssoxoficial.com and buy the
most comfortable socks in the world
and i truly do mean that these right
here these are the most comfortable
socks in the world
these are the basics they're just plain
[ __ ] great
you know they got all the licenses
spongebob wwe
just everything you could ever want yeah
i mean i'm just throwing socks at nico
blitz right now our producer is filming
this
but uh look go to oddssoxofficial.com
trust me they got the masks the boxers
everything you need my personal favorite
that i've been loving is they got the
naruto
and i'm not even into that [ __ ] but the
socks are fly and the street fighter
socks
crazy licenses odd socks official dot
com keyword
bootleg kev right now save 20 off at
checkout um
is is there anything with erica that
that you've applied
that you might have learned from working
with megan yeah like i said mo
communication like you know what i'm
saying like with me and erica
we like i wasn't taking the chance no
more with that [ __ ] we
moved us straight to you know what i'm
saying houston moved in
like we got more close to molding it in
and just so well
you know uh we won't have to have you
know if she feeling bad about something
or don't like something
you could come say it to me you know
what i'm saying you ain't gotta like
plot with the manager
and then you know y'all scheming against
me because i'm this bad guy they want to
do
something harm to you you know and um so
pretty much just like
communication and you know cause cause
you know
what she said when they came in they
said that everybody was saying this
contract was so bad but
the first thing she said hey we want
that megan contract i was like all right
60 40. yeah i mean yeah nah but i wanted
to just show a point like
you know what i'm saying you was telling
us we gave you this bad contract man
people coming in here just
like it's almost bad that it's public
because now that's the first thing
people are asking about you know
do you take what happened personally
against megan do you think it was more
the t fairest character see only reason
why you know you all you saw the spats
between me and megan is because you know
you know of course she'd like to say a
little smart stuff because she want
everybody to think she like tough you
know that's stubborn but you know we
know the real
so it's like we're gonna say something
back we all from texas too we're not
gonna let you talk
and say stuff and then we're not gonna
say nothing back especially when we know
we didn't do nothing wrong to you but
never had an issue with megan you know
what i'm saying we almost got our
business wrapped up i won't have no
issues with her then
it's you know what i'm saying i just
hate that you know
the t ferris guy i keep coming back to
that you know i moved this guy into my
house
you know for a whole year he was living
with me and we were all just doing this
stuff for him to
cross us up like that and he understood
when i came home i told him i had a plan
the plan was to build houston culture
back up
you know what i'm saying and keep doing
it it wasn't just the fun making you
know so
for when they did that it was like they
closed the doors on the city for a
little bit you know what i'm talking
about because you get all that work to
open them doors back
up and bam yeah it's crazy because when
you just what you said about
um houston culture and and and travis
obviously
he trans i mean he's brought houston
culture to the world in a way that you
know as far as you know
being called an astral world you know
[ __ ] like that but but when it comes to
like
when i was in high school and it was
mike jones slim thug
chamillionaire paul wall
you know everybody like he was in the
middle of that you know and it's like
[ __ ]
if you talk to those people they'll
probably have these same stories
right but what i was gonna say was like
that culture in houston was like
it was like it was so crazy it was wild
man
and i lived all through it all through
everything i ain't missed nothing
yeah do you think that beca because the
i don't there's so many artists popping
from houston now
but i don't think that it feels as
in sync not like not like how i had that
impact like
it it was the impact yeah the mtv viewed
it on i was
watching it it's still tipping video man
still typical
it was like yeah
it's if it like and i also feel like
there was like this this this
you know whether or not y'all know paul
wong community ended up splitting up but
there was so
there was some sort of it was like
community it felt like everybody [ __ ]
with each other
for a moment yeah yeah you know what i'm
saying right but
it was all a houston thing you know what
i'm saying it was like it was they they
it like like strut faces slim thug got
signed at pharrell and [ __ ]
you know you know you had jaina who had
houston on the map but they took it to
another level it was like
globally all that you know i like it
when i used to walk up to the plate you
know i was walking up
breaking off all that yeah it did
something different
also i was infatuated with that culture
because you know they was my age we all
same
age high school all that stuff you and
uh and and prince how did you guys
how did your relationship um start i
interviewed him a couple years ago
and you know i i it was it was great
like i said man you always saw him for
me because you know from the same yeah
he's and he's a legend you know when i
got older when i got about 17 you know i
finally met him in person
and um you know just started in and i
you know you and me from time to time
speak with him you know
for whatever reason even then you know i
was asking him about the music business
and i was using those those little tips
from when he gave me as like an 18 year
old
today you know so it was like um we
always talk about
just like uh music or life or
you know just like a little mentor type
of thing what's one thing he taught you
that you you brought with you when you
started
the direct label uh man really with him
i just like kind of learned like
patience you know what i'm saying
i need to do it now i'm typing
especially now he more like a
sit back weight to make you move type
you know what i'm saying
and you know i kind of really like that
type of way of moving because it really
lets you like think first you know
without reacting so much
you know so um you know just kind of
like that patience and
just that that mentality of that hood
but still like
you know respect and all that type of
stuff who are the top five
houston rappers ever oh
man top five houston
and you know what we will exclude
uh port arthur because you know bun bean
and
pepsi probably would be good so we're
gonna we're not gonna
you know okay if you gonna do that then
you know
you're gonna have to houston metro area
only houston metro area
all right well you got
scarface probably going to be number one
facts you know
i'll put a little flip
uh okay little key key okay i'm from the
north side so i'm gonna roll with my bar
slim third
yeah and then my last one is
fat pack all right
yeah batman listen bro i used to i used
to bang screw tapes when i was
like 14. yeah that pet you know what i'm
saying see like
like for me i i like screw area and all
that stuff but i'm from the north side
you know what i said it was like i don't
know if you understood that culture back
then
like it was just so like bad with each
other to where
it kind of gave me a death feel to the
south side
right now i'm saying but i still jammed
them but it wasn't like hot you know
what i'm saying
yeah i've heard that before uh the north
side of houston and the south side of
houston there's like a yeah it was a
rivalry yeah
it was going down because they kind of
came up with the type of
that type of rap style you know like a
little kiki
and then would switch a house from the
south side or from the north side
uh like like social house from
you know what i'm saying and they was
slim was like you know at the forefront
just
you know just bringing it to you giving
you that feel like like you know what
i'm saying so that's how he kind of
we kind of gravitated to him earlier but
plus we were seeing him like
in middle school and [ __ ] i remember
just being enamored by the fact that he
had so much
money before i even knew the [ __ ] he was
like i remember he was on mtv and he had
all these cars and these houses
and then the album came out was called
already platinum yeah he was doing his
uh
you know houston is the home of the
independent of course out the trunk
out the trunk man i feel so left out of
the loop with the houston stuff i need
to get in here i love houston
oh the man you know what i'm saying i
love him
that one line and every song that's
houston right right
so you know but you know the drank thing
kind of they taking it down so i'm i'm
wondering 10 15 years from now what's
going to happen
well yeah i mean even the drank [ __ ]
like that's
houston houston was i mean i mean come
on man
that was it i got to get what i got give
it to probably let me ask you this when
you were playing baseball
would you sip lean ever no no never
because i mean
would you even like if you were to would
that even be something that come up in
like a drug test
because it's technically cough syrup i
don't know is that a thing
is a baseball are slipping lean right
now yo like
okay what year were you drafting uh
1999.
oh [ __ ] you was it drafted with right in
the steroid era
oh oh [ __ ] did you ever participate in
any steroids when you're playing
any hgh or anything i'll still be
playing
yo [ __ ]
today's day bro barry bond his head got
so big i'll still be playing hitting 30
and still in 30 bases you know what i'm
saying
you use the base still you stole a lot
of bases yeah but see i'm one of those
dudes i really like
be worried about my body right now i was
scared that you know i was gonna put
some [ __ ] in there and
i don't know you know i'm saying i was
always worried about that your right leg
stopped working huh
it's just take the wrong thing it was
tough you know cause you got every
pitcher
in the steroid area everybody throwing
97.
ain't nobody throwing under 98 miles per
hour
i just had to get through it the best
way i could wow
what yo which pitcher in your opinion
was the the
the one who scared you who you were like
[ __ ] here we go yeah [ __ ] i have to face
randy johnson i'm from arizona come on
man brady johnson
that's your boys
randy johnson my favorite picture ever
coming from way behind you
[ __ ] randy johnson and he's [ __ ] like
six foot ten yeah he's hot see now cece
he was a tough pitcher as he left the
tube i hit him well but he kicked him
from the top
brenda johnson coming from right here so
randy johnson was the guy who sticks
out yeah okay um
when you played baseball this was so the
sami sosa mark maguire thing happened it
was 98 i believe
right so you come the year after i
remember
um that that that was like uh
luis gonzalez was on the diamondbacks
and hit like 56 home runs and it was
like the first time he ever hit over 30.
that's that's what it is you know what
was going on yeah
i ain't never get caught so i mean come
on i mean we got a [ __ ] world
series in one you know what i'm saying
yeah but it was just a it's it's it was
a historical
time in baseball because i'm always i'm
for the steroids for the record
that's what they say definitely let
everybody just look do what the [ __ ]
y'all one more
you can see me hey you know how much
better the ratings would be if everybody
was jacked up
they let them do steroids then they
tighten the balls up you know what i'm
saying so it was like
that was just jumping that's why you
were saying was there
like we always hear about um
cheating going on the astros just had
that cheating scandal that was crazy
we hear about people corking their bad
[ __ ] like that with that kind of [ __ ]
that could be happening
i was playing against samuel sosa today
when his back got croaked you know what
i'm saying like oh you were there yeah i
was in left field
so i'm sitting there like yeah what's
that you don't say the bat broke you
know what i'm saying
[ __ ] already hitting 60 homers a
year he still got a call and he's still
cheating well now we
well you know he's on steroids as bad as
corks
oh now he's okay and now he's caucasian
now he's a white guy you see that
[ __ ] sammy sosa
he uh like a cuban michael jackson man
we said he pink now at this point
yeah we like man he hit all these homers
already
he's cooking his back how much more does
he need yeah so
i'm just going to show you man hey if
you ain't cheating you ain't trying
that's what they say
all right so you pay for the dodgers you
uh you play for the raise right
uh the red sox where else did you play
that was it that was the three
you spent the most amount of time in
boston in tampa
i used to [ __ ] listen man i lived in
tampa i lived in saint pete that's why i
live too
man i lived right on 4th street 73rd
avenue
listen man i was in i was in saint pete
tearing them down boy
man hey hey oh
both hey we might have some we might be
uh you know
what do they call that when you hit the
same chick and not know each other uh uh
that's my brother that's my brothers oh
yeah definitely eskimo brothers
i was taking down a few raised girls for
sure
no no no a few of the rey's girlfriends
yeah yeah you know my boy buckwheat
orlando from wild 941 buckwheat in
orlando the nuthouse and those guys
that's my
can't believe it either he like man [ __ ]
you know what i'm saying cause you know
they watch me play with the rage
so now he like you know see i'm in the
music you know
so you playing with the rays so you went
to the world series in no way was you
i was not i went i was there for uh way
after that
but i remember that team and uh
i feel like that team kind of um leaned
a little bit on kind of like the money
ball right like as far as like
they they did on the money ball but they
um
we had joe madden you know what i'm
saying yeah legendary coach
belief system you know what i'm saying
like it wasn't even past the money but
it was just the whole
mind statement you know what i'm saying
and i didn't think nobody can really get
into my head like that you know what i'm
saying but he came in and like got it
best coach you played with
yeah he probably the best one because
because because no matter how negative
you get
he would never let you get negative you
know what i'm saying
like for example i'll be you know mad
about something with a teammate i'll be
like y'all till this [ __ ]
okay well i don't know what happened
today you know what i'm saying and i'll
be back
i'll come back go on joe office
give it to him just like i told
everybody else and he'll just
bam let me get it out right just start
breaking me down
this and that and but in the comments
you know you're not yelling right
i think that that's the weirdest sports
venue i've ever been to
tropicana field because you're in there
and it don't feel like you're
in a baseball game it feels like some it
feels like carnival or something
it feels like you're at a carnival
that's exactly what it feels like like
it's the state fair or something
like there's like there's some sort of
like gun convention going on down there
like
that was that that was had to be a weird
place to play i mean i like
you get used to it i'm sure you know
what i mean it's not going to be hard
it's perfect temperature
and stuff like that because you really
appreciate that when you start playing
on like when i went to boston i was like
damn you know i'm used to the game
starting on time every day at seven
perfect and uh now i got this cold
weather and i'm just
you know uncomfortable all the time so
but have you thought about signing
anybody from tampa because you know
about i'm sure you know about tom g
and yeah artists
well you know rob rod waves from st pete
oh yeah
yeah he's from the 727 man he'd be
banging that [ __ ] too
there's a lot of up-and-coming dope like
young cats that are moving
yeah bro i thought orlando
now oh oh it's chilling always make too
much money to worry about it he's and
he's
oh yeah he's killing him yeah oh he's
orlando got all the rappers i thought he
meant orlando
from wild our friend no orlando's
booming two jacksonville
but saint pete tampa got some [ __ ] man
and tom g's still rapping shout out to
tom do you remember tom g from back in
the day
i wasn't really in tune with the uh with
the music scene back then like that i
only knew
when i first got there man they told me
i had to listen to trick daddy
mm-hmm um plies
did you ever go to club sky what was
that
yeah i mean if it was on evil okay okay
fair enough well look uh we appreciate
you pulling up man um congratulations on
the label and
and you you there's another artist that
that yeah we got another artist coming
up by the name of stunner bam you know
he got this song called rock out with
erica banks and uh you know he's been
doing where's he from
from houston i appreciate you i mean i i
appreciate you putting on for the city
man
that's what i came home to do that's
what you said i'm gonna look more into
it for
just just because you came i'm gonna
look more into it cause i don't know i'm
lost
everything y'all was talking about i'm
like okay
there it is man hey we appreciate you
pulling up and uh thanks for your time
bro
perfect